il y a la partie visible de la
coopération russe et biélorus la
signature d'un accord de coopération
militaire et la contrepartie moins
visible
nous avons signé des documents prévoyant
le déplacement d'armes nucléaires non
stratégique russe sur le territoire de
la République biélorus dans une zone
prévue à cet effet
c'est la première fois depuis la fin de
l'union de République socialiste
soviétique en 1991 que la Russie déploie
des armes nucléaires hors de ses
frontières Moscou gardera le contrôle
des missiles pour Minsk le parapluie
nucléaire russe servira à la défense de
son territoire le président Alexandre
lucachenko se félicite du déploiement
rapide des têtes nucléaires
la décision a été prise pour concrétiser
ce que nous nous étions dit oralement il
a fallu s'organiser et préparer des
zones de stockage on a réussi et donc
les ogives nucléaires sont déjà en cours
d'acheminement
cette décision rendue possible par une
récente mod application de la
Constitution biélorus inquiète les pays
voisins membres de l'OTAN Pologne
Lituanie Lettonie et Estonie Washington
parle d'une décision irresponsable et se
dit vigilante nous condamnons fermement
cet accord l'utilisation d'armes
chimiques biologique ou nucléaire dans
ce conflit aurait de graves conséquences
mais en réponse à cette information
j'ajoute simplement que nous n'avons
aucune raison d'ajuster notre posture
nucléaire stratégique ni aucune
indication que la Russie est prête à
utiliser une arme nucléaire
pour Moscou ce déploiement est une
réponse au livraison occidentales
d'armes à l'Ukraine de quoi inquiéter
cette dernière alors que des soldats
russes avaient attaqué le pays via la
Biélorussie au début de la guerre en
dernier qui est estime que 10 000
soldats russes seraient encore
stationnés en Biélorussie